i appreciate you talking to me about
season two and that we could even say
season two it was delightful to get to
see new episodes again
i i'm sure it was nice for us to shoot
them
yeah we enjoyed making them yeah i mean
the first season seems like it was out a
lifetime ago and now the second season
is coming out so a whole global pandemic
happened in between yeah it's crazy
so what do you
what are you most excited about fans
getting to see with season two
i mean the what we or at least for me
what i had the most fun doing this
season was just
the initial shock of this world and what
it is and what these keys are and what
they mean and who these people are
that has worn off
a little and we have our sea legs now
and we got to come into season two
and just have more fun
in this world
um and that was really enjoyable for me
as an actor so i hope that people
watching will feel something like what i
felt shooting it which is just that they
know these characters they know the
concept they know the world and now we
can just play and it's freer and more
open and it takes us
into more exciting places because those
those rules are already there
i think for me there's a couple of
things there's a sort of a new to build
on what conor said there's a new
course issue of of power that the lock
siblings have to grapple with you know
um in season two there are the forging
of new keys or or people attempting to
do it and you know the audience gets to
find out who can make them and who can't
and and why these characters are making
them
um it's uh
those are fun issues i think to
get to see the characters explore for
the audience
and i also love the way dodge has
shape-shifted into gabe it's a
completely new villain energy
this season i mean dodge liza's dodge in
season one was fantastic but so
no tren you know so so obvious i mean so
dodges wears a a black robe and she's in
your face and this dodge is undercover
and subtle and you know
cannot i mean has dark dark plans and
it's all very secretive
and uh so that's a different form of
evil uh
that the locks
have to confront
which makes it more intense yeah yeah
it's scary i mean
yeah
he certainly has a great menacing face
yes
he does
well you guys have not only done a
second season but you've also done a
third season and in that time these
characters have taken pretty big
individual and life journeys
how different does the character feel
now from when you first started playing
them on day one now that you have gotten
through three seasons how different do
they feel
quite different i mean it's like it's
funny to
to go with a character over that long i
mean it's sort of like the difference
you know like when you buy a new pair of
jeans
um
and then and it like it barely fits and
like it's not quite right and like it's
tight in some places and loosen others
and then you wear it for a while and
suddenly it almost feels like a
different
pair of jeans like it's like it's
something fits better and it's like it's
it gets you second skin yeah um
and i really do i mean it's a silly
analogy but i think it's pretty accurate
um you know by the end of season three
especially
uh i felt
like this character was just lived in
you know like i felt like i i understood
him more intuitively
um
you know in season one i there's so much
thought in every episode every scene
like where is he now what's he thinking
about what's he worrying about what's he
coming from why is he saying that's what
he said and
and that was really present and in
season
season two and even more in season three
a lot of that just felt more
natural uh like it was it was just there
and and it was clear and it didn't
require a whole bunch of um
of digging to find
i love uh i love
nina locke i love her heart i loved
um
playing her back to back seasons two and
three um
part of what made this
um
these two seasons so special for me
is um
you know i really like this cast and i
like the connections that i have with
these other my fellow actors um
i find working with
connor jessup amelia jones jackson
robert scott and the whole cast truly um
really easy it's just organic uh i i
have really instinctual
real sharp instincts with each of them
i like them as individuals i think it's
a really
a great bunch talented
so
to get to create with uh people that i
enjoy
uh both personally and professionally um
makes it
i feel like you can go deeper in a way
so
uh you know
nina lock's heart for me
was like it's not just something i i
sort of put on but i sort of found
through these people
so that's what what made it special for
me
you have some wild things going on in
this season
yeah
from a giant spider to
a large glass used to trap a person
creepy mannequins that are going it's
especially weird yeah and the creepy
mannequins are going to be haunting me
for the rest of my days
and even just the whole destruction of
that insane house toward the end of the
season what was your personal favorite
visual moment from this season
i there's a lot of them and
they
i i found with me it was like a nice
rhythm or like once every two weeks of
shooting i would get to do something
truly ridiculous which is like which is
like
the best possible rhythm i think
like it it keeps you really having a lot
of fun
um
at the end of season two there's a
sequence
um when that house is collapsing
where emilia and i were
suspended
in the air for a long period of time
flying together and that was
really really fun
we laughed
a lot
so that that image will always stay with
me
and then the visual the visual of what
the audience will see is truly stunning
it's it's
it's visually
it turned out our special effects on
this
they did such a good job you know um so
that moment stands out and for me
another moment with jack and jackson
robert scott actually
i do believe that uh
it's it it pertains to a key and i do
believe it's used by maybe all of the
the lock siblings but he in particular
uses this key
in the beginning of season one and um
you know he's pretty tiny
and it has some to do with something
that makes him seem not tiny and it's
just um
it's it's it's delightful
yeah i mean there's just so many just
crazy things that happen in this season
i loved it
especially as a photographer i i see
things with that perspective so it's
so fun when there's so many wild things
going on
well i'm curious connor with tyler i
mean obviously anything spoilery i will
save till after it's a spoiler
this season we see tyler come to terms
with forgetting what magic forgetting
what that'll actually mean
you know by not being able to remember
it anymore and and
it's not like with his uncle and his
mother who just can't remember it he he
really sort of has knowledge of what's
gonna happen to him
yeah what was it like to explore that
especially in the relationship with his
girlfriend where you know it just was
heartbreaking to
see them share this thing together but
for him to know that it's just slipping
away
yeah i think that that
dawning awareness of transience
is something that we can all identify
with and for tyler really starts to feel
at the beginning of season two that
they're approaching a cliff you know
so much of who they are and his
relationship with jackie and his
relationship with his siblings is is
built on
his awareness of this magic
and
as he realizes that that might go away
he wonders if all that comes with it
will go away as well and he starts to
get really scared by that and what it
will mean for him and for jackie and for
everyone um
and
i think for him it's it means more than
just
not being able to see or remember magic
anymore for him so much of his identity
now is tied up in this um and so much of
of his hopes for the future
are tied up in it um
and so i think it really starts to get
to the core of who he is and what he's
scared of and what he wants
um
and that's a lot that's his real score
in season two
yeah i mean he gets to a place by the
end of the season where he makes the
choice
not to use
the memory key and to have a normal life
so
what can you say to tease how that might
affect things for season three
and i mean is and whether or not that's
a decision he can even stick with
yeah i mean you know he
he turns around at the end of season two
and he he has been through he's so much
painful he's been through so much pain
toward the end of season two that he's
he realizes that he's not equipped
to hold that at the moment and that it's
it's easier to just drop it you know
literally to drop it to let it go um
and
he
you know i don't think he leaves season
two at least i didn't feel like when i
left season two that that was
resolved for him that that was the end i
mean he
he his relationship to these keys and
his relationship to himself by proxy is
not finished um
so going forward i think that he
he can run
but uh but he can't hide it's the same
goes
well darby if given the choice would
nina choose to be aware of and to know
about magic and the role that it plays
in the lives of her family that she
doesn't even know how deeply affected
they are by it oh yeah that's such a
good question
i don't think anyone's asked that before
my instinct says that nina would
want to know i think nina wants to be
connected to her children i think that's
something that she's
um that she's that she needs and maybe
even more so
since the passing of
you know randall locke's murder
um it's it's she's the only parent and
in season one she questions her ability
to parent she questions her ability to
bear in season two as well
um
so she puts a lot of pressure on herself
but she all it just means so much to her
so i think
you know if given the choice i think
that she would
uh
would like to know um
because then maybe you know she would
finally start to get some answers
yeah it's so hard to watch that dynamic
because you can tell this family loves
each other and yet yeah he's still kind
of it's not even really lying they just
know she's not going to remember it yeah
it's heartbreaking to watch the the this
lock siblings you know sort of not not
have them i mean i think they even say i
think doesn't tyler say like we can
either have drunk you know
mom drinks and she sees magic or you
know but they don't want her to because
that's you know she's not well and
that's not you know that's not what they
need that's not what she needs so it's
really it's such a curse on this family
that for as much as they
want to be a family they're they're a
part
they're they're pulled apart
there's a sort there's a sad moment for
me it's not a huge moment in the show
but it stuck out to me when we were
shooting it
when
we've been we've been running away from
this giant spider and duncan is with us
and
we come out into our ruined kitchen and
he is wondering what the hell just
happened
and he's asking all these questions and
tyler says something along the lines of
um
just wait just wait a second and yeah
this like inevitab this inevitable
loss that it's not even worth trying to
connect with him about what they just
went through together and to me there
was something like
on the script it didn't come across
necessarily as like
sad
but there was something when we were
playing it that just felt hugely sad to
me that there was like he has this
person who he wishes that he could
multiple people who he wishes could be
there for him with him
to help
and just can't
um and that that the inevitability of
that loss
struck me in the moment is pretty sad
yeah i felt the same way watching the
moment between nina and bodhi when he
just he sort of gives her this gift so
that they can
walk through her memories but he knows
that you know he will remember that
moment but she won't i mean there's just
something so
emotional and moving about that
yeah jackson he the way he played that
it was you could see it written all over
his
his whole being it was really quite
moving
to see yeah
yeah he still wants to share that moment
even though
he knows that they won't both
retain it
yeah same moment
as connor's speaking of yeah
yeah well i appreciate you talking about
this i had so much fun with the season
there like i said there's so many crazy
things in it that i just like
he's a three
you